In the beginning was the word
and the word was with God.
Somebody actually has memorized this.
I'm so proud of you.
I got me some good Sunday school people
in the class or at least somebody who's
done the reading for the day
and the word was with
God and the word was God.
He was in the beginning with God.
All things came into being through him.
God,
what a philosophical sounding term being
it screams to be capitalized like Hagle
or someone like that would do being,
do you sit around in your dorm room
worried about being what is the nature of
being was the nature of existence?
Yeah,
no.
If you do,
you're a good philosopher.
What has come into being now that's
also very philosophical in traditional
classical philosophy from Plato on being
is one kind of thing and coming into
being is something else.
Things that are truly, truly,
truly being don't come into being because
that means at one time they were not.
Man, this sounds so philosophical and
the life was the light of all people.
The light shines in the darkness.
The darkness did not overcome it.
You skipped down a bit.
Verse 14 the word became flesh and lived
among us and we have seen his glory,
the glory as of a father's only
son full of grace and truth.
That sounds not only philosophical
but downright feel illogical.
Okay?
No one has ever seen God.
Good theological point, right?
It is God the only son,
God the only son.
Have we heard anything like that kind
of language so far in this course?
God,
the only son?
No,
we haven't.
That sounds like a Christian creed.
It doesn't sound like Matthew,
mark and Luke. It doesn't sound like
acts. It doesn't even sound like Thomas.
We're in a different
world with this gospel.
This is not like anything
we've seen so far.
So from the very beginning
of the gospel of John,
you should know you're in a different
world from the synoptic Gospels, Matthew,
mark and Luke, the style, for
example, over and over again,
the style is repetitious.
Their phrases and words that come up
over and over again, darkness and light,
light and darkness.
I already did some of that with the the
we're in the beginning was the word.
The word was with God. The word was
God. He was in the beginning with God.
All things came into being through him.
Without him,
not one thing came into being what has
come into being come into being repeated
three times little clue. Don't write
your exit. Jesus papers like this.
This is not good American
English riding style.
You're supposed to vary your terminology
right a little bit and alter your
terms.
That's good English writing style.
This of course is actually fairly
good ancient Greek writing style.
It's just that different
writing styles are different,
but it's also a writing style
that we haven't seen so far,
so there's this repetition of words.
They're memorable sayings in the gospel
of John that you don't have in other
places.
There's a whole lot less action in the
gospel of John and a whole lot more talk.
Just flip open the gospel of John almost
any place and it'll start off with a
scene,
often a conflict scene with Jesus and
kind of as conversation with other people,
but pretty quickly it will
go into a dialogue in which
Jesus is saying something.
The other person says something,
go back and forth a bit and then it
goes even from a dialogue into Jesus.
Just being chatty Cathy and
just talking for paragraphs.
We don't have any of this kind of
stuff in the synoptics of Jesus.
Just going off on tangents for paragraphs
at a time and talking for a whole
chapter sometimes and that's what
you get in the gospel of John.
There are some scenes in the gospel of
John where the characters look actually
more lifelike than they do
in this synoptic gospels.
Have you noticed in the synoptic gospels,
the characters sometimes are
just a tax collector, a sinner,
a Pharisee,
a Syrophoenician woman,
a centurion who had a slave.
Most of the time they don't have a name.
Most of the time they just say
one or two things to Jesus.
One of the longest conversations with
Jesus that we have a with another
character is precisely the
Syrophoenician woman. You've, uh,
you've read about where you remember she's
comes and says she wants her daughter
to be healed and she's not a Jew.
And so Jesus says,
it's not right to take bread from the
children's mouths and throw it to the dogs
calling her a dog and
undeterred. She says, yes,
but the dogs got to eat the crumbs
from under the master's table.
That's one of the longest dialogues
that Jesus has with another person,
not his disciple. In the
synoptic gospels, very different.
We get to the gospel of John.
We have this scene,
we'll go to it in a minute where Jesus
has a whole chapter talking to Nicodemus.
We're told to nicotine is,
is we're told a little bit about him and
then Jesus has a conversation with them.
We have a whole scene in which Jesus
is talking to this woman at the, well,
a American woman.
We know more about this woman that we
know about just about anybody else in the
synoptic gospels.
We know that she's had seven husbands.
How many people do we know that about? We
know that, you know, she's a Samaritan.
We know where she lives,
we know that she goes out to draw water.
So there are a lot of places in the
gospel of John where characters actually
look much more lifelike and
filled out than they have been in,
uh,
the gospels that we've read so far.
This lecture is going to
focus on the gospel of John.
But as you've already figured out,
one of the main themes of the course is
how were the different forms of early
Christianity different from one another.
It wasn't just one movement.
It's not like some new
religion just sprang out of
the earth or fell from heaven.
So one of the things that the course has
been to look at the different kinds and
the gospel of John and then the letters
of John First, second, and third, John,
which we'll talk about next time, are a
wonderful example of this. And in fact,
what if you look at the syllabus,
today's lecture constitutes a certain
shift in the syllabus because although I
am talking about a gospel and I'm talking
and I have been talking about gospels,
I put a little subheading under,
uh,
this week that sort of like the spread
of Christianity and how Christianity,
different Christian groups look different.
We talked about that with,
with the book of acts last time,
but this time what we're going to do is
we're going to use Johanan Christianity,
just one of those fancy scholarly words,
just rest verse two different
kinds of John Christianity.
So we've got the gospel of John and we
have the three letters of John and they
are similar enough,
although it's quite debatable whether
they're all written by the same person.
We'll talk about that when we
get to the letters of John,
but they're similar enough in their
writing style and in their terminology and
their theological themes that we believe
that all four of these documents,
the gospel of John First
and second and third,
John Represent one form of early
Christianity and we're going to call that
Johannen Christianity.
Or somebody who might pronounce it
Johannie in Christianity the same thing.
So this lecture is going to focus on that.
So let's first look at the narrative
differences in the gospel of John.
I hope you notice this when
you're reading through it. First,
there's this prologue that I started
reading at the very beginning of the
lecture.
It has several major themes that
will occur throughout the Gospel,
and it's just packed into this prologue.
There's first,
Jesus is preexistence in no other gospel
do we get the idea that Jesus existed
before his birth?
That's counterintuitive to a lot of us
because whether you're a Christian or not
a Christian,
you're used to thinking about Jesus
as an eternal divine being who becomes
incarnate as a human being,
but always existed.
That's not in the other
gospels if you noticed,
but it's definitely here
in the gospel of John.
So we get the preexistence of Jesus and
his divinity right there in the prologue.
You get this theme of life.
You get this theme of light and darkness.
Jesus comes from light. He
comes into darkness. The
darkness doesn't receive him.
He brings light to his followers.
There's the coming into the world.
The world is not simply the
physical world that you and I know,
it's the cosmos,
the Greek Word Cosmos,
where we get the word cosmology,
all the universe.
So Jesus comes into the cosmos.
So the cosmos as a dark enemy,
place in which Jesus
invades it in a sense, uh,
is one of the major things with the
gospels that you get right here in the
prologue.
The world is a place of enmity.
The world hates Jesus.
The world hates the disciples.
The word hates you if you're a
follower of Jesus, birth from God.
So there's this idea that
people are born from God,
son and father linkage over and
over again. God is God is Jesus.
Father in the gospel of John Is.
That's true in some of the other gospels,
but it's just much more so in the
gospel of John, John The baptist,
as the lesser of the two is introduced
right in the prologue. We don't,
we don't take a while to get to John.
We have John the baptist,
right in verse six, there was a man
sent from God whose name was John.
He came as a witness to testify to the
light so that all might believe in him.
He himself was not the light. This guy
wants you to know from very beginning.
John the Baptist is not Jesus equal.
He's secondary witness just
so you don't get confused. Um,
there's the idea that
the law comes from Moses,
but grace and truth come from Jesus.
And there is this emphasis on seeing
and knowing as we'll talk about later.
And I hit some of the
major themes of the Gospel.
The seeing and knowing are two
definite themes for the gospel of John.
And it's all right.
They're wrapped up in the prologue to
the Gospel so that John is different from
anything else. Because in this
very, very elaborately constructed,
poetic sounding,
almost philosophical sounding prologue,
you get lots of the major themes of the
Gospel just laid out for you another.
So that's a narrative difference.
Another major narrative difference is
the relationship of Jesus and John the
Baptist and the synoptic gospels.
Jesus,
his ministry does not begin
until the arrest of John.
Did you notice this?
Jesus goes to John the
Baptist to be baptized and it
looks like Jesus in a sense
as almost a disciple of John.
Although the gospel writers
try not to tell it that way,
but Jesus doesn't start his own preaching
ministry and his own healing ministry
until the Ministry of John the Baptist
is over. So for the synoptic Gospels,
John the Baptist Ministry comes here.
John the Baptist ministry stops.
Jesus has starts very clear
and the gospel of John,
that's not the way it is.
There two ministries overlap each other.
So for example,
sometimes John the Baptist is
baptizing and Jay and the Gospel.
John tells us that Jesus and his disciples
are baptizing and another part of the
Jordan. What we don't hear anything
like that. And the other gospels,
Jesus and his disciples over here in
another part of the Jordan baptizing their
disciples while John is
baptizing his disciples.
And then sometimes John's disciples
leave John and go over and join Jesus and
then there's some discussions between
them. Sometimes John The disciples,
John did John the Baptist disciples
come and ask Jesus the disciples, well,
you know, what is your master to
do about this or this or that?
So there is an overlap of
the two ministries that you
get in the gospel of John
and you don't get it all in the other
gospels. Another big difference,
Judea and Galilee,
if all you had were the
first three gospels,
the ideas you had had was that Jesus,
his entire ministry took place basically
in gasoline until the last part of his
life.
And then he journeys to Jerusalem
and according to the gospels,
he's only basically in Jerusalem for
one week and then he's crucified.
That's not the way it is. And
the gospel of John, in fact,
did any of you notice where is the
cleansing of the temple incident and the
synoptic gospels? When does it
happen? C'Mon, c'mon, c'mon,
wake up. When does the cleansing of
the temple incident happen in Matthew,
mark and Luke?
All three of them.
I'm sorry. At the end, right?
Unlike maybe Wednesday
before he's executed,
it happens the last week of his life,
right before he was arrested. In fact,
the Gospel is present that as maybe
one of the reasons that he is arrested.
When does it happen in the
gospel of John Chapter Two?
Is it two? I can't remember.
This is it really too?
Okay it heck yes. It happens at
the very beginning of the Gospel.
I couldn't remember exactly
what chapter with that. Good.
So the cleansing of the temple happens
at the beginning of the gospel of John,
not the end. Uh, like in the others, uh,
the length of Jesus's ministry
in the synoptic Gospels,
if all you have is an optic gospels,
it would look like the Ministry of
Jesus probably lasted maybe a year.
Not much more than that. There's just
no indication of how long it takes.
But he goes to Jerusalem only
one time for the Passover.
And that's at the end of his life.
In the gospel of John,
there are three different
mentions of Passovers.
There's the Passover in chapter two,
verse 13.
This is when he goes up to Jerusalem
and cleanses the temple there.
There's another Passover mentioned in
chapter six verse four and there's another
passive that mentioned in 13 verse one
that is the Passover that's at the end of
his life when he's arrested.
So there's three Passovers that occur
in Jesus's ministry according to the
gospel of John.
Have you ever heard the tradition that
Jesus was 30 years old when he started
his ministry and his
ministry lasted three years,
so he would've been dead at
33 you may have heard that.
Do you know how people got that tradition?
It's not in the Bible anywhere.
They get the 30 year old idea from reading
some passages in Luke and the idea of
when he started his ministry,
they get the three years from
lean reading the gospel of John.
So notice how they've taken one little
detail about Jesus' life from Luke,
a different detail from John.
They combined them together
to give you the tradition,
but no gospel actually
has that teaching in it.
Christians have pulled these gospel,
the details from the gospels together.
That's because Jon's the only one that
indicates that according to his reckoning,
do you use this man? Administry
covered at least three Passovers.
The other gospels don't have that.
Jesus has parents and hometown.
According to Matthew,
Jesus is family is simply from Bethlehem.
That's where they start off.
That's where they end up.
So Jesus families from Bethlehem,
Jesus later goes to Galilee.
According to the gospel of Luke Jesus,
his family is from Galilee.
They go to Bethlehem only for the census
and then a month or so after the birth
they go back to Galilee.
So you've got differences right there.
Matthew simply has used his family from
Judy at in the beginning and they ended
up moving to Galilee after they go
to Egypt. Luke has them from Galilee,
go to Judea, go back to Galilee. John
doesn't have anything about this Bethel,
him birth. In fact, he has an,
in chapter seven verse 31 people say,
how can you be the Messiah who says the
Messiah supposed to come from Galilee
and [inaudible] have to come to a gallon?
There's massage was come from Bethlehem.
Yeah,
and the writer of gospel of John,
wouldn't it be a great time if he
could just say, oh, these stupid Jews,
they don't know that Jesus actually was
born in Bethlehem and therefore he is
from Judea. He doesn't say anything
like that. He just allows the reader,
you the reader to believe that,
yeah,
Jesus really watched from Galilee and
you know what? That doesn't matter.
They must've gotten it wrong.
They must not have thought that the
Messiah could actually come from Galilee,
but he can. So again, the gospel of John
Different and its narrative structures.
The last supper,
the last supper in the synoptic
gospels is a Passover meal.
The last supper in John
is not a Passover meal.
Yeah.
In fact,
also the last supper is not the
institution of the Eucharist and John and
Christian churches.
We observe the mass or
the Eucharist and we say,
Jesus established this in his
last supper with his disciples.
Do this in memory of me.
Yeah.
That goes back to Matthew, mark and Luke.
The Gospel of John doesn't have that.
There's no place in the gospel of John
where Jesus initiates the last separate.
He doesn't take the cup.
He doesn't take the blood and say,
do this in memory of me. What happens at
the Last Supper in the gospel of John,
he has a foot washing.
There's a foot washing ceremony.
Notice again what Christian
tradition has done here.
Any of you know what Maundy Thursday
means and Christian churches?
Monday, Thursday refers to the
Thursday before Good Friday,
which is the Friday before Easter and
on Good Friday, according to the uh,
tradition Jesus was executed the
Thursday night before is when the he has,
the last step was disciples.
Now,
in many Christian churches on
the Thursday before Easter,
not only will they have the Eucharist
service so that our communion service,
but they'll also have a foot washing
service at the church where I go,
the priests,
the different priests will actually get
down on their hands and knees and put
towels around themselves
and washed the feet. I mean,
anybody in the church who comes forward
on Thursday night before Easter,
they're doing that in imitation of
Jesus's foot washing of his disciples.
At the last supper in John, but
notice what we've done here. Again,
Christians have combined the last supper
and the Eucharist establishment from
the synoptic gospels with the foot washing
service from the gospel of John and
they put them together but they
weren't together in our Bible.
They were in two separate documents.
The arrest is also very different in
the synoptic gospels and it's an optic
gospels.
They come to arrest Jesus and they just
arrested him and there's a few things in
the gospel of John is
funny, funny, funny scene.
It's actually very humorous where they
come up with the swords and the clubs,
you know it's middle of the
night and the garden and they,
they come to Jesus and a Jesus says
who you are looking for and they say,
Jesus of Nazareth and Jesus says, I am
he and they all fall over in the ground.
It's like an Indiana Jones thing.
They,
you know the power of him saying this
knocks them all over and they get up and
do it again and they all fall over again.
The whole scene of the arrest
of Jesus is very different.
The Gospel of John at his trial in the,
in the synoptic gospels,
Jesus says almost nothing.
This an optic.
Some of the synoptics say he said nothing.
Others if they're not going to say
he said something, but he's very,
very quiet and the gospel of John,
he just carries on this whole
philosophical discussion
with pilot about what is
truth.
He just keeps talking and talking.
Very different scene on the crucifixion.
There's some differences.
Remember I'm here for rehearsing just
narrative differences between the first
three gospels and John.
These are places where just the
story is different and its details.
According to the first three gospels,
the crucifixion takes place
on the first day of Passover,
the Thursday night supper.
Remember in Jewish calendar
reckoning a day begins at sundown,
so on sundown of Thursday night,
that's beginning of Friday
and in the synoptic gospels,
that's the beginning of the Passover.
So they wait until sundown and they have
the Passover meal Thursday night and
that's the beginning of Friday. The first
day of Passover and it's on the Friday,
the first day of Passover that
Jesus is actually executed.
That's not the way it is.
In the gospel of John.
Read the Execution Narrative
in the gospel of John.
According to the gospel of John,
Jesus is not crucified on
the first day of Passover.
He's crucified on the day before Passover.
And how do we know that?
Because it says when they were crucifying
him was the same time they were
executing. They were slaughtering
the lambs in the temple.
Notice it's a wonderful little
symbolism, right? Right.
When Jesus being slaughtered,
the lambs for the Passover meal are
being slaughtered because what you do of
course,
if you are a Jew and Jerusalem,
you'd take your lamb to
the priests on Thursday,
you'd have them slaughter it, pour out
the blood, that take a little bit of it.
Then you take it back home to your family
or to the hotel where you're staying
or to the picnic ground where you're
staying and you cook your lamb and that's
where you have the Passover meal.
So according to the gospel of John,
Jesus is executed at the same time
that they're slaughtering the lambs,
which means he's not executed
on the day of Passover.
But the day before Passover,
completely different.
And the last big narrative difference
with the gospel of John from the synoptics
is this guy named the beloved disciple.
Who the hell is the beloved disciple?
We don't know who he is.
According to Dan Brown and the,
what's that awful book? Um,
Davinci Code, right?
According to Da Vinci Code,
the beloved disciple is actually
a girl, Mary Magdalen, I guess,
cause he couldn't believe that Jesus
could be, you know, attracted to a guy.
So he had to invent a girl to be the
beloved disciple and heterosexist.
As you know,
modern novelists are no,
the beloved disciple is a man and we
don't even know who he is. He's Jesus,
favorite disciple and the gospel of John.
This character doesn't
exist in the other gospels.
He's just not there. Now, tradition has
said, who is the beloved disciple? Well,
it's, it's the John's son of Zebedee,
younger brother of James, son of Zebedee.
And if you go to the art gallery,
which you will later in the semester,
we're all gonna take a
tour of the El art gallery.
You'll see that when John son
of Zebedee is depicted in art,
he's always depicted as a young man
without a beard. Very beautiful,
almost feminine looking.
Cause he's sort of representing
the boy that Jesus loved.
Well we don't know that it was John.
The Gospel of John doesn't
tell us it was uh, John.
It just tells us is the beloved disciple.
So most scholars just willing to say
whoever this beloved disciple was,
and maybe it was just a figment of the
literary pretensions of this writer.
Maybe there was no historical
beloved disciple. We don't know.
But he's a strong character in this gospel
and he doesn't appear any place else.
But in this gospel
notice in all those ways,
the gospel of John is very different
from the other three gospels.
That in itself makes it
really interesting to study.
It opens up a window for
us of an different kind of
early Christianity then we
would have if we didn't have this gospel.
So it's really wonderful.
Okay,
so major Johanan themes.
I'm going to go through this pretty
quickly because if you just take a
concordance and look up these terms,
you can look at all the
different places first.
Notice that some of these main themes,
I've already mentioned,
some of them when I was
talking about the prologue,
these main themes occur over
and over and over again,
like the ringing of Bells
in the gospel of John.
Every once in a while you'll see one in
one chapter and then you might not hear
it to the next chapter,
a few chapters later,
but then they'll just keep coming up.
So this author hits you over the head
several times throughout the gospel with
the same themes coming back at you.
One of them is the descending
and ascending redeemer figure.
Jesus is, uh, the one
who came down from above.
Who's going up.
Look at one 51.
Now we're going to run like
bunnies through the text here.
So get your text out and be prepared.
Lick your finger.
Come on, look your finger. You're not
going to get sick. It's your own finger.
One 51 and he said to him,
very truly, I tell you,
you will see heaven open and the angels
of God ascending and descending upon the
son of man. So the angels are
ascending. Look at three 13
no one has ascended into heaven except
the one who descended from heaven.
The son, the son of man. Look at, uh,
three 31. The one who comes from above is
above all the one who was up the earth,
belongs to the earth and
speaks about earthly things.
The one who comes from
heaven is above all.
And I could go on one 30 to six 38,
six 41,
six 58,
2017.
Just look up this coming and rising and
you look up these words in a concordance
and you'll find they recur over and
over. And again, the gospel of John,
very similar to that one is
the theme of being lifted up.
So Jesus and three 14 and 1232 in
eight 28 you don't need to see,
remember these numbers because you've got,
you can look at a concordance and you can
read this and you can just mark out in
the margins of your Bible. Whenever
you see this idea and all of those.
Jesus is the one who will be lifted up.
And this is a puzzle.
One of things we'll find it the gospel
of John Likes Puzzles. He likes riddles.
So what does this mean when Jesus talks
about the son of man being lifted up?
Does it mean his ascension into heaven?
Does it mean his
resurrection from the dead?
Does it mean his being put on a cross?
Because when you nailed
somebody on a cross,
you did it on the ground and
then you put them up like this.
So does the lifting up of the son of
man refer to his crews or fiction or as
resurrection or his ascension?
Going back to the father.
It's a puzzle we're never told.
Exactly.
And that's one of the wonderful things
about this Texas that it plays with you
all the time. It wants you to wonder
about what's being meant here.
So that lifted up is one of the themes
that goes along with this going up and
coming down.
And then another part of that theme,
see these things get complicated is when
Jesus says, everyone who comes to me,
when I am lifted up, I
will lift up. So God says,
so Jesus says he will lift up
people who are his disciples.
So this going up and coming down
is all the way through the gospels.
That's one of the main things
I mentioned seeing. Okay,
we're going to run like bunnies
through the text. One 18
no one has ever seen God.
It is God the only son who is close to
the father's heart who has made him known.
Oh, now see I should told you,
knowing is another theme there.
We got two themes right in the
same versus seeing and knowing.
And the relationship between seeing and
knowing and the gospel of John is also
difficult.
It's not always clear.
Do you know by seeing or is seeing the
seeing lead to an inadequate farm of
knowing these are big exegetical problems
that the gospel of John Poses and
scholars argue about.
Look at one 34 and I myself have seen and
have testified that this is the son of
God. Okay, I have seen, look at one 39
he came to them,
come and see.
They came and saw where he was
staying and there it's just looking at
concordance for every
time you find the word,
see saw seeing and you'll just
find it over and over again.
Uh, chapter three verse three,
Chapter Three, verse 11 chapter three,
Verse 32 chapter three, verse 36, several
right there in chapter three, et Cetera,
et Cetera, et cetera. And
again, it's always a little
bit difficult to figure out.
Do you have to see to have faith in the
gospel of John or because it sounds like
one place toward the end of the Gospel,
Jesus says,
blessed are those who
believe without seeing.
Is this the Thomas busted or you, you, you
saw and so you believe so. That's okay.
Blessed are those who
have not seen and believe.
So as seeing an inadequate form of faith,
is it better to have faith without
seeing or seeing necessary for faith?
It's a problem. I already
mentioned knowing, but I can
do the same kind of thing.
A chapter one verse 18 Chapter Eight
verse 55 chapter 14 verse 17 over and over
again where Jesus came from and where
Jesus is going is a major theme with the
Jews off. And he'll say, you can't
go. You can't go where I'm going.
And they say,
what is he talking about going,
you're going to go out to the
Greeks and preach to the Greeks,
going to go back to Galilee.
What am I going?
So there people are always
misunderstanding this.
And then one of the other points is signs.
How do sign?
What are signs in the gospel of John?
Notice the gospel of John has other that
I haven't even mentioned. For example,
member in the synoptic gospels,
there are lots of exorcisms of demons.
Do you use is going around a lot,
casting out demons from people
and the demons even confess him.
Do you know there's not one
exorcism in the gospel of John.
Jesus is not an exorcist in the gospel
of John as he is in the other three
gospels.
Why is that?
Obviously this rider knew that there were
stories circulating around that Jesus
cast out demons.
Why does he not have Jesus doing any
casting out of demons in his Gospel?
I don't know.
There's probably a dissertation.
There's somewhere you can find an answer.
Look at two 11
so one of the things is that in the
other gospels they talk about Jesus's
miracles, his healings, but the term
preferred by this gospel writer,
his sign, he talks about the things you
use do as sign. There's not a lot of them.
Jesus doesn't do a whole lot of
miracles in the gospel of John,
he does some big important ones.
They become famous, for example,
turning water into wine,
which is of course every college
student's favorite miracle of Jesus.
If only he had turned it into beer, that
might've been a little bit better, right?
But Jesus is famous for turning water
into wine, one of his major miracles.
It's only in the gospel of John.
It's not in the other gospels.
So some of Jesus' famous Gospel, a famous
miracles are in the gospel of John,
but they're not called miracles.
In John, they're called signs.
So look at two 11 Jesus did this,
the first of his signs,
this is the turning the water into wine
in Caina of Galilee and revealed his
glory and the disciples believed in him.
Notice the first of his signs.
Let's look over it a little bit.
Four 54
yeah.
Now this was the second sign that Jesus
did after coming from Judea to Galilee,
the second side.
This has actually led some scholars to
say that one of the sources this rider
may have had is a signs book,
a collection of signs that
his miracles that Jesus did,
but notice they're not just a miracle
that Jesus does and then casts off.
I think that the,
this,
the author uses the term sign because
most of the time you can actually do an
exit.
Jesus of these signs,
narratives and they have some
kind of symbolic meaning.
So the signs and and,
and gospel of John are not just
miracles to prove Jesus's power.
They seem to have some kind of theological
or symbolic meaning embedded into
them also. So the signs again is one of
the major themes of the gospel of John.
But one of the most important things
that drives the gospel of John is
sectarianism.
What do I mean by sectarianism?
According to sociology of religion,
a sect,
it's not necessarily just an insult.
In other words, you don't just say, Oh,
you're just a member of some
crazy little sect out there.
Handling snakes are doing
other kinds of things.
A sect is a sociological term
that refers to any group,
whether it's religious or not,
although we usually can to use us in
religious context that considers itself
very well cut off from the rest
of society. So for example,
I grew up in a very,
very sectarian fundamentalist
church in Texas.
By sectarian,
I mean that we basically believe that
we in my church were the only ones going
to heaven.
So in fact,
we would call each other brother or sister
and you wouldn't even call a baptist.
I mean, we were, we thought the
southern baptist, we're going to help
you know that that's how much we were.
The only ones there were no,
there was nobody who was, who
was right, like we were, right.
So you'd call each other brother, brother
Lamar, all the old men in the church,
especially we call brother.
But you wouldn't call people
brother who were outside that group.
So we were the only Christians. You
had to be in our group. In fact,
people would even talk about, you know,
something like if you, if you, if you, uh,
brought somebody to church as a visitor,
somebody might come up and you say, well,
is she a member of the church?
They didn't need to say our church
or our denomination, the church,
because the church meant our church.
So this,
what made this group of sectarian
group was we had very firm boundaries.
There were debates about whether it was
okay to marry outside of that boundary.
Could you actually marry
a Methodist? Oh God, no.
And God help you aroma Catholic.
So the stronger the walls,
the stronger the walls between
your group and outsiders.
The more sectarian your social group is.
John's church seems to be
a very sectarian group,
and that's one of the things people,
why is he talked so much about dark
and light. These are stark divisions.
Insiders,
outsiders,
up below there are children of
light and children of darkness.
They're children of God and children
of Satan. There's no in between.
There's no gray area.
You're either in or you're out.
So scholars define this by talking
about Joe Hannan, sectarianism,
the insider,
outsider divisions.
And we're going to look at
one place where that comes up.
Look at chapter nine.
I'm going to spend a little more time
with this chapter because some scholars
have used this to say what's
going on in the gospel of John?
So get chapter nine, get
your bibles out. You know,
I may lie to you,
this is a story about Jesus
healing a man born blind.
So I'm going to skip around, do
it. But uh, first he heals him.
And then nine verse 10, they
kept saying, Kim, that is this.
Arounders then how were your eyes opened?
He answered,
the man called Jesus made mud,
spread it on my eyes and said to me,
go to salon and wash. Then I went
and washed and received my sight.
They said to him, where is
he noticed this? Where is he?
How do your eyes open?
Yeah.
And he says, I do not. No, no, no, no, no.
I now see, see, see where, where,
where is he?
Okay.
They brought him to the Pharisees.
The man who had front of him right now
was the Sabbath Day. That, wait a minute,
hit verse 13 for crying out loud.
We'd been 12 verses into this chapter
in this story and only at verse 13.
Are we told that it's a sabbath
day. Why not? Why is that? Well,
because apparently what started
out as a simple healing story,
this author has decided to
turn into a conflict story.
Have you noticed it in a lot
of the stories of the Gospels?
Some stories just seem to be
straightforward. Miracle Stories.
Other stories seem to be nature miracles,
like not just healings, but he, uh, uh,
power over nature.
And then there are lots of stories
that are conflict stories that is,
you're told that someone was healed.
But the real important part of the story
not was not necessarily just that they
were healed,
but that they were healed on the sabbath.
And that starts a conflict between Jesus
and other Jews about what's permissive
permitted to do on the Sabbath.
By the time you get to verse 13 what
started out as simply a healing story,
although it may have had symbolic meaning
because the man's blind and he comes
to see,
and those are big important themes for
gospel of John now becomes a conflict
story over the sabbath.
Yeah.
So He, he tells the story
again to the Pharisees and,
and a chapter and verse 1317 so
they said again to the blind man,
this is the farracies. What do you say
about him? It was your eyes. He opened.
He said he is a prophet.
Okay, so that's important.
The Jews did not believe this is
verse 18 then he had been born blind.
They received a site until they called
the parents or the man who had received
his sight. And ask him, is this
your son who you say was born blind?
How then does he see his parents said,
we,
we know that this is our
son and that was born blind.
We do not know how it is that he now sees,
nor do we know who opened his eyes.
Ask Him. He is of age. He'll speak
for itself. His parents said this.
This is the narrator speaking.
Now,
his parents said this because
they were afraid of the Jews.
Now wait a minute,
okay.
All the people in this story are Jews.
Yeah.
Jesus is a Jew. The blind man's
a you. His parents are Jews.
They're all Jews.
Why are we talking about some
people being afraid of the Jews?
For the Jews had already agreed that
anyone who confessed Jews to me,
the Messiah would be put
out of the synagogue. Now,
I hate to pay her folks,
but that's just outright anachronistic.
There was no movement going on during
the life of Jesus where anybody that
confessed anybody to be a
synagogue would be x. Communicate.
I mean Jesus to be the Messiah would
be excommunicated from the synagogue.
That just didn't happen.
There were all kinds of people
who thought were MSI was around.
There were debates about this,
but you didn't have any synagogue.
Ruler is going around saying,
well, we're going to make a rule.
Anybody who claims that Jesus of Nazareth
is the Messiah will be excommunicated,
will take their union card away from them.
They can't come to high holidays.
We will return their dues.
It just wasn't going on.
Now, it may have been going on decades
later when this guy wrote the gospel.
You see,
so what's now we'll keep reading.
What's going on here,
of course is what you believe about Jesus.
The Messiah has to do with whether you
will be allowed to stay in a synagogue.
If you take Jews to be just a profit,
you might be allowed to stay.
If you confess these messiah,
you'll be kicked out of the synagogue.
That's the basic conflict of the story,
so we keep reading and there's a,
they go into more and more conflict.
Look at verse 30 then the man answered.
There's basically saying, look,
we know Moses, this guy can't
immune Asya. He must be wrong.
The manager here is an astonishing thing.
This is the man born blind whose now
sees you do not know where he comes from.
Comes from, comes from,
comes from, comes from,
and yet he opened my
eyes. See, I see, I see.
We know that God does
not listen to sinners,
but he does listen to
one who worships him.
In no basis will never since the world
began has it been heard that anyone
opened the eyes of a person born blind?
If this man man were not from God,
Oh God. Oh God, okay.
He could do nothing.
They answered him.
You are born entirely in sins
and are you trying to teach us?
And they drove him out.
They kicked him out of the synagogue.
Jesus heard that they had driven him
out any. When he found him. He said,
do you believe in the son of man?
He answered and who is he, sir?
Tell me so that I might believe in him.
Jesus said to him,
you have seen him and the one speaking
with you is he? He said, Lord, I believe,
and he worshiped him. Jesus
said, and this is how,
this is how the story ends.
Okay, so this must be important.
I came into this world for judgment so
that those who do not see may see now as
Jesus still talking just
about blind people. No,
we can see that the whole
story was an allegory now
and those who do see may become blind.
Some of the Pharisees near him
heard this and said to him,
surely we're not blind are we? Jesus
said to them, if you were blind,
you would not have sin.
But now that say we see
you're thin remains.
Some scholars have pointed out that
what's going on with this chapter,
chapter nine in John is a wonderful way
to see how the rider himself has taken
what may have been a simple miracle story
that he got from tradition about Jesus
healing a blind man and he does a couple
of things with it. For one thing, he,
he pulls up to the surface this,
these themes about blindness and seeing
and coming from God and this is all
plays into the identity
of Jesus as the Messiah.
And then he tells the story like the blind
man is sort of like someone who comes
to faith in Jesus as the
Messiah and he recognizes it.
But sure enough,
if he really confesses that he's got
to be thrown out of the synagogue.
And so he leaves the synagogue
and he joins up with Jesus. He,
he's thrown out of the
synagogue. He becomes a disciple
of Jesus. In other words,
[inaudible] is speaking,
he has to leave the synagogue
and therefore he becomes
a member of John's church.
There are other people who suspect
that Jesus may well be the Messiah.
They want to confess them and they don't
do so that cause they're afraid about
being excommunicated from the synagogue.
Notice how this story has
become an allegory for what's
going on in the time of
the writing of the piece itself.
The Gospel rider is telling
a story about a blind man,
but he's also telling a story about the
conflict that his church is having with
the synagogue in the neighborhood.
Yeah.
This and the main thing that's going on
here also is that Jesus is the one who
brings about this
division that takes place.
What's the main focus of the division?
Christology. Remember I talked last
time about different Christologies what?
What Christology is is what do you
believe about the nature of Jesus Christ?
Is he just human? Is it
God? Is he some of both?
Is he a prophet? Is He only a
prophet? Is he a moral teacher?
Is He only a moral teacher? Is he the son
of God? Is he equal to God the father?
All these are options and the first
several hundred years of Christianity is,
is all wrapped up in fights over which
of the many different options you have
for what you believe about Jesus is
going to end up being the right one.
What's going to end up as orthodoxy?
The Gospel of John is a wonderful place
to see this very thing starting out.
So look at chapter five verse 19
Actually No,
we're going to go back and look at,
yeah, that's right.
Let's go look at five 19.
I'm going to back up in a minute and
go back to some other, uh, dialogues.
Don't worry, I'll on time today, but
we will probably take up again, uh,
some of the gospel of John next time
before we talk about the letters of John
Chapter Five, verse
19, Jesus said to them,
very truly, I tell you, the
son can do nothing on his own,
but only what he sees the father
doing for whatever the father does,
the son does.
Likewise,
the father loves the son and shows him
all that he himself is doing and he will
show him greater works than
these so that you will not,
you will be astonished indeed,
just as the father raises
the dead and gives them life.
So also the son gives life
to whomever he wishes.
The father judges no one but has given
all judgement to the son so that all may
honor the son just as
they honor the father.
Anyone who does not honor the son does
not honor the father who sent him. Verily,
truly,
I tell you,
anyone who hears my word and believes
him who sent me has eternal life and does
not come into judgment,
but has passed from death to life.
Look at five 18 right before that.
For this reason,
the Jews were seeking,
hmm.
Yeah.
For this reason,
the Jews were seeking all the more to
kill him because he was not only breaking
the sabbath, but was also
calling God his own father. Now,
that's so far we've,
you've gotten in the narrative,
but notice what the the author
ads right after that, the law,
the next very phrase,
thereby making himself equal to God,
is every son always equal to a father?
Go like this?
Nope.
All sons are not equal to all fathers.
The Gospel writer is editorializing
because this is what he believes.
He believes that not only is Jesus God's
son in some kind of derivative sense,
he believes that by saying that God's,
that Jesus is God's son,
he's actually equal to God.
The father.
Look at eight 58 I'm going to come back
and talk about chapter eight next time.
There's this chapter eight is one of these
classic scenes in the gospel of John,
which start out with Jesus just talking
to someone in what seems to be a cordial
and relatively peaceful mood.
And then as the conversation goes on,
things get more and more heated
and people accused Jesus of things.
But Jesus is just as bad.
He accuses people of stuff all the time,
ridiculous stuff.
Some time like they're children of Satan
and the whole thing ends up with this
big division and everybody's starting to
throw things at each other.
And then the next chapter will start
and you'll see them talking again.
And again,
it comes down to a big division.
So this is the end of chapter eight which
is one of these scenes of a discussion
turning into a fight, turning into
a brawl, turning into a division,
and where does it end?
Chapter Verse 58 Chapter Eight
Jesus said to them, very truly,
I tell you before Abraham was,
I am.
So they picked up stones to throw at him.
Yeah.
Isn't that interesting?
All he has to say is I am.
Why is that so much of a problem
where it is? I am come from,
yes.
Yeah.
That's the declaration of what God is.
When God says I am.
To whom and where in the Bible,
Moses in front of the burning Bush,
exactly the very name of God,
which those of us who are non Jewish,
we use to say is y'all way.
There are only four
letters write in Hebrew,
and those four letters don't
have vowels attached to them.
So we're not really sure how to
pronounce them. And your English Bible,
they're usually translated
by lord in small caps.
Whenever you see lord in small caps in
your English translation of the Hebrew
Bible,
that means that the Tetra Gramaton,
the four letters of God's
name or in the Hebrew,
but according to Pius Jewish usage,
you'd never pronounced those.
So you'd say something like
the Lord as a substitute.
And that's the way in
the Greek Bible it does.
Since the Greek Bible didn't
know what the name was,
it just would say Adonai the
Lord or something like that.
And so we'll use that
in English translation,
but that scholars think that perhaps the
best translation for those four letters
as they occur in accidents
is beingness or I am
knows what Jesus' saying.
He's claiming to be the one who
spoke to Moses out of the bush.
That's radical.
That's way more radical than anything
we've seen in the other gospels.
Jesus could be the son of
God and still not be God.
Jesus could be the son of the father
and still not be equal to the father.
Jesus could be the the Messiah
and still not be divine,
and Jesus could be even the Messiah
and divine and still not be.
I am in the gospel of John.
Nah. Ah. Jesus says, I am.
He's the one who spoke to Moses. It's no
wonder that the Jews tried to stone him.
We'll talk about that further next time.